Prepare for the all-new sequel
to the franchise reboot
based on the sequel
to the original franchise.
Star Trek Into Darkness.
Uh, did someone forget a colon?
Get ready for the sequel that JJ Abrams swore
would be different from Star Trek II:
The Wrath of Khan.
Except for this part:
"The needs of the many Outweigh the needs
of the few."
And this
And of course:
(screaming)
That.
But JJ's not just stealing from The Wrath
of Khan;
he's recycling everything you loved about
his last Star Trek movie, too,
like Kirk bedding aliens,
Spock throwing tantrums,
Kirk and Pike drinking,
Red Bull Space Jumping,
hallway running,
Old Spock,
and
even
more
lens flares!
Ah, you guys get the point.
So, ride once again with James T. Kirk,
the galaxy's worst star-fleet captain,
as he desecrates a culture's gods
"What the hell did you take?!"
"I have no idea, but they were bowing to it!"
Lets experienced crew members go out of spite.
"Do you accept my resignation or not?"
"I do!"
Promotes inexperienced crew members out of
convenience.
"You're my new chief."
"Aye, captain."
And fails to protect his crew.
(screams)
And the Enterprise.
And downtown San Francisco.
Cringe at the stereotypical treatment of the
two female leads.
Uhura, an otherwise competent officer,
who stops a life or death mission
to nag her boyfriend for not sharing his feelings.
Uhura: "You prefer not to discuss this at
all, that's what you prefer."
Spock: "Our current --"
Kirk: "Are you really gonna do this right
now?"
Uhura: "What never seems to require your undivided
focus --"
Kirk: "Guys."
Uhura: "I'm sorry, Captain. Just two seconds."
And newcomer Carol Marcus,
who's only there for one reason
Carol: "Turn around!"
Make that two reasons.
Watch as this crew faces their most dangerous
enemy yet.
Khan: "Khan."
He's a ruthless villain
Khan: "Shall we begin?"
so diabolical he'll... not kill Spock,
let Kirk express his feelings,
and ultimately be completely justified in
his actions.
Khan: "My crew is my family.
Is there anything you would not do for your
family?"
You gotta admit, he's got a point.
So! Boldly go to a ridiculous alternate Star
Trek timeline,
where the Enterprise survives more hits than
it took
in the entire original series,
magical interplanetary transporters make star
ships obsolete,
death has been cured by magical super blood,
Bones: "I synthesized this serum from this
super blood."
and, whenever they're in a space jam,
old Spock is just a FaceTime away.
Old Spock: "Mr. Spock."
Spock: "Mr. Spock."
Ugh, I can just picture the next Star Trek already.
[dreamy music]
Klingon General Chang,
The Horta,
Tholians,
The Borg --
all really bad!
Anybody else we should look out for?
We covered The Gorn, right?
It is just a test. Do not actually kill The
Gorn.
Correct. Oh, and when you go back to 1930's
New York you have to kill Kirk's
girlfriend or Hitler will win World War II.
Fascinating.
Oh and be sure to track down a couple humpback
whales. Cause that will save you a
lot of time later on.
Humpback whales...
That should cover it. Now I believe you have
something for me...
You lucky dog. Best I could get was that weird
fan dance in Star Trek 5.
Are we sure this is not going to rip apart
some time-space continuum?
Hey, you want my help or not!?
Starring...
Captain Twerk
Smock
Old Smock
Margaret Cho
Carlos Santana
A Doctor, Not a Miracle Worker
Bling-ons
Scott the Engineer
Robocop
Thumbnail
And Eggs Bennedict Cummerbund
Star Trek Into Darkness
Are we SURE we don't wanna put a colon in
there?
Thanks for watching.
Set YouTube to subscribe.
Big thanks to How It Should Have Ended!
You guys rock!
Check them out here.
Ever wanted to see what this buttery voice
looks like, or who makes the Honest
Trailers?
Click here to see the making of this Honest
Trailer.
Welcome to Good Burger, home of the Good Burger,
can I take your order?
I'm a pretty pretty princess.
Kick his ass, Sea-Bass.
Tread lightly.
Khaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaan!